the part that I really don't like and
the part that's feeling very sort of
like Communist China to me is like the
forced apologies that's the scary part
to me I see that as you know I still
describe myself as liberal but I see
this as like the real sort of almost
unsolvable problem of liberalism that
liberals always want to be open and
decent and understanding and all of that
but then when a movement that is so
totalitarian and crazed and and wants to
progress no matter what it's progressing
to liberals don't seem to have a good
defense against that where conservatives
seem to actually have it better well I
feel like I've never felt like I've
never felt it practical to pick a team
and then pick all that is that team and
and so all all answer in a roundabout
way I I love cars I have a bunch of race
cars
I Drive a bunch of race cars I have a
lot of different cars like because I
love cars and you know sometimes I'll
talk to guys and they'll go I'll go oh
they'll go you're a car guy I'm a car
guy like you love cars I love cars and
then I go what kind of cars do you like
and I go I'm a Mopar guy everything I
gots a Dodge everything's got a Hemi in
it everything's and I'm like well you're
a car guy but you just have this one car
it's kind of like going I love the
ladies but only Porter it's like hop on
a blonde and a black chick and a redhead
like if you really love women what's
wrong with all of you know all of them
you know like that's right thing it's
like if you really love women go out
with a whole bunch of different women
and I feel now I finally believe like
you're not racist there you go you're
willing to bang every type of thing
that's
the the and I sort of treat my world
politically kind of like I'm just
pushing a cart through a Trader Joe's
like I'm not really into the Nilla
cookies over there but I do like that
jerky you know and I at some point the
cart will start to take shape I guess
and you'll go well this guy likes his
meat or he likes his protein or this
person likes their carb carbohydrates or
whatever and so for me it's like
conservative well I'm not religious I'm
basically an atheist and I'm not a gun
person but I'm not anti God I'm sort of
pragmatic gun I've sort of realized like
when you read op-eds and the Los Angeles
Times about should we arm the teachers
what difference would it make if one of
those teachers at Columbine had a gun
what difference and then they go they go
three kids dead eight kids dead 15
what's the difference I'm like what's
the difference the difference is three
versus 15 but so like I didn't make a
pretty big difference to the fourth kid
who would have died if the teacher
wasn't armed so it's like I'm not buying
into this cockamamie doctrine of what
difference would it make
but my thing is like I'm not religious
and I I don't have real strong like sort
of conservative whatever upbringing or
values but I do understand that intact
families and a focus on education and
having a patriotic the patriotic part
just sort of loving your country not to
the point where you know you've covered
yourself in the American flag or driving
a pickup truck but I mean like
appreciating your country like going oh
okay we've made mistakes but you know
what is there anywhere else you'd rather
live you know like that leads to a sort
of happiness and pot legal gay marriage
legal whatever else do your own thing
I'm not I'm very interested in
if I'm not hurting you I should be able
to do what I want to do and if you're
but but the problem with the left is the
left is saying let us tell you what to
do and if you say something that we have
not vetted or approved we shall remove
you from your job and that kind of
McCarthyism of no one can work because
you had a transgression from eleven
years ago in a yearbook or whatever it
is I don't like in the part that I
really don't like and the part that's
feeling very sort of like Communist
China to me is like the forced apologies
that's the scary part to me like the
announcer that is talking about the
Baltimore Ravens quarterback and it's
like well he's getting tone as dark the
ball is dark that jerseys dark he has an
advantage that at some point he has to
go I regret saying and realize that my
hurtful terms looks like you don't
regret it
these weren't hurtful terms we want you
to analyze football and you've actually
brought up a point I've never thought of
which is it takes a millisecond for the
outside linebacker who's coming around
the corner you're trying to get him to
bite on this play fake you're trying and
just as if I was a if I was an
african-american boxer and I had brown
gloves that I kept them close to my
chest and you had red gloves I'd have a
little advantage I could see I could see
the red gloves coming a millisecond off
of versus the brown gloves off of the
brown skin color and this guy was
basically making the point that at the
defensive end and then he went on to say
how great the quarterback was so he's
making a point it's an interesting point
and he's right the guy can't the guy
does a great job of staying with it the
balls hard to spot the outside
linebacker fights on it and he goes he
goes around him for a touchdown and he
has to pretend to apologize because he's
going to get fired and when I
here to me the heartbreaking part of the
whole thing is the apology yeah at the
outraged culture and on it it's the
person with the prepared statement
begging for you not to relieve them of
their job that's the part that feels
like Twilight Zone wish you out to the
cornfield like hey hey it's a good thing
it's a real good thing boy it's a good
thing you did like everyone's scared to
get wished out into the cornfield and
now they're having to apologize and
there's so many crazy examples that
remember when Mark Duplass seems a
Hollywood producer and actor who's been
on my show he's we're friendly and he
said he sent out that tweet that he
basically said Ben Shapiro is not the
devil and then he had to apologize like
it's like he didn't endorse the guy he
didn't say you agree it was in effect
like he's not a horrible person and then
you know and so and it's it's like
Orwell in but it's also McCarthyism yeah
it's like you look III know the de
plasters they're good guys yeah that was
hardly good work they they're they live
now the only way to stop this out is for
everyone to tell everyone to [ __ ] off
and not do it but the marked applause
does shows with HBO
they're very woke this may not hurt him
but are you taking that chance I mean
you got a production company wife and
kids employees you got a business you
know what I mean and what he's doing is
he's going me saying ben shapiro is a
good guy even if i preface it with it
you may not agree yeah there's a hole
however and then getting a bunch of
blowback maybe HBO it doesn't think
about that yeah maybe they don't i have
25 employees do i want to take that
chance I don't want to take that chance
so I'm just going to issue this cowardly
statement basically distancing myself
from a guy who helped me out I mean it's
completely disingenuous it's it's
cowardly and but but hey I got a job I
got to keep my job like this is this was
great so now you and I do
have-have that or maybe it's not helping
your eye I don't know I don't care yeah
if we want to work for HBO you want to
sell product HBO you better be careful
what you say who you associate with and
who you do business with or who you
praised all right so the last thing so
we can wrap up with the movie oh yeah
you talked about that Praeger guy before
there's a sort of fun moment in the
movie where you talk about how different
you guys are like you just everything
about you you just said you're basically
an atheist you know he's a at least
somewhat religious you you're up rings
are completely different everything
about you guys is completely different
yet you guys came together on this thing
and you were touring in colleges before
this and all that can you just talk
about that a little bit well you know I
think we do a thing which is you see how
I brought it around so that you could
promote the movie I do love that wasn't
that professional no insiders you also
got a chassis chass wide come and see
all these motor racing docks I've made
if you like that I don't like this world
I was just talking about this yesterday
where it's like we need diversity and
people of color and the and the fire
department should represent the
community that it that it serves and
it's all that it's like well so what
your skin color is the same color like
what what really is that you're the same
yeah you know what I mean like Dennis
and I have common sense
he has buckets of common sense I'm very
rooted in common sense we have nothing
in common but we do have common sense
and that trumps everything if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the non-stop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlists they're both right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell